ted cruz's cast votes that some
Democrats don't like rather than wait
until the election two weeks now to vote
against him some decided to scream at
him and his wife in a restaurant
thank you sir god bless you I believe in
due process shame on you Ted Cruz bless
you man shame on you Ted Cruz changing
minds and annoying travelers at the same
time that wasn't a restaurant of course
that was Washington National Airport
Cruz is not the only lawmaker getting
yelled at these days Mitch McConnell
recently screamed at in a restaurant
also watch
[Music]
you want to live in this country of
course you don't
most people are horrified by it some
people though defend it former Hillary
Clinton aide Philippe rains recently
said that the public harassment of
lawmakers was a made-up problem he joins
us safely thanks a lot for coming on
thank you for any to defend that I
assume I wasn't defending Ted Cruz I
attack those could have been Republicans
chanting and set careers the way he's so
unpopular look screaming at people in
public places is not you know ya argue
it's protect where the first moment
that's fine but it's not the way that
people should behave it's not anything
we should defend and it's not the
country were gonna live in is it well
let's be clear what happened first the
first instance of this was Sarah Sanders
who write what's in a in Virginia and
was ejected she was asked very nicely to
leave she was asked nicely more than
sometimes you're nice to me in terms of
questions so I don't think that that is
a heavy price to pay for someone who
lies with impunity every day to the
American people so you worked for
Hillary Clinton this husband was
credibly accused of rape if your mom it
was not clearly he's accused of rape by
someone with all kinds of
contemporaneous like kids I'm just
saying that he was accused of rape so
you could see someone saying well
Philippe defended this his mother gave
birth to him why should she be allowed
to eat in a restaurant it's within
bounds to say Philippe's mom please
leave
how would you feel about that nobody was
protesting Sarah Sanders mother it was
Sarah Sanders because she works for a
guy they don't like look I mean I'm just
I mean first of all she has free will
she doesn't have to work there it's an
honor and a privilege to work there well
you don't have choses every day did you
like it if she chooses every day to lie
to the American people people are seeing
public officials and they don't see any
accountability and they're thinking to
themselves elections elections are two
weeks I mean what what point is this
okay I mean 100 days ago I mean you know
I'm not the angry mob 100 days ago I
started a protest outside the White
House right have oil viewers like Kate
Rudy who know that I couldn't hurt a fly
Donald Trump he's trying to shut that
down because he doesn't want protestors
outside okay
I guess the point I'm making is should
is this is it okay or did things start
to fall apart I'll tell you what's not
having this kind of nothing it's not
okay lots of things aren't okay 642 days
since Donald Trump was sworn in not one
of those days has he said we've got a
dial down the rhetoric I'll tell you
what he did say in the last few days in
the last few days have you see has
specifically Kratz panned I'll tell you
what I saw he specifically we're not in
power we're not that's something to hold
us accountable to know because your
youth in the last the week actually
follow you are doing this I mean I know
I must have ten people have been yelled
at until they had to leave restaurants
all conservatives is that okay with you
I am okay with Sarah Sanders secretary
Nielsen and Mitch McConnell yes Mitch
McConnell was more in danger of
Salmonella in that restaurant and he was
Larry Clinton no he's been restaurant
and I walk up she leaves there's
somebody something being unpleasant and
something being okay I would say if
you're protesting something you're
disagreeing how about you separated
children from their parents and I went
to dinner at a Mexican restaurant I
would realize how about if I endorsed
third term abortions I mean there are
lots of things I disagree with and find
repugnant that you support but I mean
you're not a few hugger
no so is it okay to scream at Nancy
Pelosi until she leaves a restaurant and
the answer is no it's not okay I never
okay I think what happened with Nancy
Pelosi was fine the other day she was
walking out of a fundraiser and a group
well she was with her don't see any you
don't see any of us looked up and said
Nancy Pelosi I'm gonna yell at you until
you leave the palm because you have a
party you support a policy I disagree
with I think a normal person would say
you know if you're creating hypothetical
that's not what happens conservatives
don't do it because they're not monster
in the last 10 days
Donald Trump used the name George Soros
for the first time in his presidency and
the guy had a pipe bomb in his mailbox
last night and we're talking about
whether or not whether or not Sarah
Sanders gets her corner and what a pipe
bomb and George swati's McMahon what do
you think they did I think it's just
coincidence sighs George sorry cuz rich
Donald Trump
runs away because George Soros don't
laugh I'm laughing because - driving
between Trump Soros I've criticized show
us a thousand times I hope you live long
enough I'm not Donald Trump he has
elected leaders and not less George
Soros come on in 642 days there's an
angry mob if if we've gone from coconut
juice and soy to angry mob and everyone
is so worried about violence why has
Donald Trump but not said everyone needs
to dial it down the rhetoric and our
society I think he has never said that
Tucker mob Sigma so P but I was like oh
mom you're racist racist Democrats an
angry mob well they are an angry job
angry mobs it's catchy
but he needs fear and hatred to succeed
he has no he's great it's his
responsibility I'm gonna let you dine
I just can't bribe you kid Trump Hotel
no one yelled at you exactly